this lady as though she just not a fun
for me bad flavors bub
Oh bacon observation Lea Lea Lea little
ago she just fell far from over that
hoof butyl happy my nose was like that
where that one pull those extensions
that's a [__] hoof I on Lisa a little
I'm a bad [__] drop 54 pounds
555 little [__] sack of [__] yeah bad
flavor oh yeah
will the Ray be over here they
conversing about Leon walk the [__] away
[__] post office up [__] and that's
it it's a Sunday beautiful day you drop
yes we drop these on down but they see
have a good week there's a holiday
League East and we go to Christian I'll
get your fire going and we'll hug
everybody
[__] well Pharaohs of the Excel
approximate okay he's misbehaving he's
gotta get it together
happy hardcore let's stay black yeah on
the set and grudge match in my trailer
with the TV little [__] couch there
flavor a little bathroom little closet
there
my [__] notes my phones getting
charged up you know how we do it
we're here on the Senate grudge match
I'm about to rehearse with De Niro for
the first scene what do you not do you
know I'm saying this is what the [__] I
work for [__] stay black I'll be
back Joey coupled is a grudge match that
flavors well giving it to you live my
man P the signal director mr. DeNiro
Shmuel his trainers and myself right
here [__] okay my main man here
all right with doing grudge matches do
all these are these [__]
savages
they're all here the [__] cameras the
boom girls there's a real [__] movie
all right say hello to the people home
good
No
you know okay funny is great cheaper
his wife works dead body shop
they passed the Safety's on
the body shop
customer service
rock'n'roll
thank you guys for coming up
[Music]